MaMartine Biron, Alec Castongua,
StStéphanie Grammond.
BoBonsoir à vous trois.
- - (tous): Bonsoir.
- - On n'en a parlé au tout débt
dede l'émission, j'en ai parlé
avavec Sébastien aussi un peu de
cece rapport de la coroner Kame.
ElElle va l'on ne l'attendait
pepeut-être pas. Je vous demande
avavant les recommandations
prprincipales.
UnUne santé publique indépendan,
fifin des CHSLD privés, et
imimplanter des ratios sons et
rérésidents sécuritaires.
SiSi on ne vous a pas dit ça au
momoins 1000 fois, on ne vous la
papas dit une fois. Martine,
prpremier commentaire sur ce
rarapport. Elle est assez
élélogieuse envers la ministre
BlBlais.
- - Elle ne blâme pas vraiment e
popolitique. Elle blâme plutôt a
mamachine, je dirais, dans des
didirecteurs, des PDG de CIUSSS,
etet des médecins aussi. Elle et
plplutôt tolérant à l'égard du
popouvoir politique.
AlAlors, disons que le dossier t
asassez documenté. On sait qu'iy
a a eu des ratés, des ratés
imimportants. Mais c'est clair,a
plplupart des conclusions
dédémontrent que le système de
sasanté était dans un état
pipitoyable. Alors elle libère
MaMarguerite Blais.
EsEssentiellement, parce qu'elle
cocollaborait et elle a levé le
drdrapeau rouge en disant : les
CHCHSLD, vous êtes en train de s
ououblier. Mais le niveau de
popouvoir de Marguerite Blais, l
n'n'était pas si élevé que ça.
C'C'est une ministre délégué. Ue
miministre délégué n'a pas de
bubudget, c'est en fait un
adadjoint, si vous voulez, au
miministre de la santé. Alors la
baballe va plus dans le camp de
DaDanielle McCann, membre de la
cecellule de crise. Elle a choii
lala coroner Kamel, de pas blâmt
lala cellule de crise.
- - De ne pas blâmer le politiq,
cocomme vous le dîtes bien.
AlAlec, qu'est-ce qu'il se resst
dede ça selon vous?
- - J'ai un Kamel relève... de a
coconfusion un peu. Visiblementn
nene pas visiblement cru le
tétémoignage de Danielle McCann
ququi disait que des débuts
jajanvier ont demandé au CHSLD e
sese préparer, alors que la
coconsigne était tout sauf. Mais
elelle ne va pas plus loin que .
ApAprès ça, c'est beaucoup des
cicirconstances qu'on connaît :
ququand est-ce qu'on a commandée
l'l'équipement de protection
inindividuelle.
OnOn retrace un peut la génoisee
cecette catastrophe, mais pas ac
dedes nouveautés par rapport à e
quque la vérificatrice, et les
auautres, ont sorti.
IlIl y a des choses là-dedans je
pepense qui sont déjà dans les
cacartons. Je pense que le
prprochain directeur national de
sasanté publblique sera indépen.
JeJe pense qu'on est déjà rendu
llà. Mais comme celui qui est
nonommé les parts intérim, ce ne
sesera pas maintenant. Mais le
prprojet le sera.
LeLes CHSLD 100 % privés, sa
titire à sa fin.
IlIl y a rien qui donne des
mumunitions à l'opposition. La
cacampagne électorale approche,
esest-ce que ça va être une bom,
esest-ce que ça va sauter au
vivisage de caquiste? Il n'y a s
grgrand-chose là-dedans avec
lalaquelle l'opposition pourrait
fafaire du milage.
- - Stéphanie, elle aurait pu
rerecommander... elle en parle,
mamais c'est vraiment une phrase
ququi permette la latitude de
gouvuvernement, elle dit, il
dedevrait y avoir une
rérétrospective. Ce qui voulait
unune...
- - on pourra parler de façon
ththéorique tant qu'on voudra, n
réréalité, c'est que la CAQ n'en
fefera pas de commission.
CeCe qui est intéressant, c'este
didire : OK, où en sommes-nous
rerendu?
OnOn voit qu'il y a une crise
épépouvantable avec ce rapport,
dadans les CHSLD, mais ça faisat
dedes années que les problèmes
peperduraient et que rien ne se
fafaisait pour remédier au
prproblème. Quand on lit le
rarapport de la vérificatrice
gégénérale qui est sortie il y a
ququelques jours à peine, ce qun
coconstate, c'est qu'il n'y a
totoujours rien pour régler les
prproblèmes. En CHSLD, tout ce i
esest soin de longue durée, il y
a a pas assez de place pour
héhéberger tout le monde en ce
momoment. Et le gouvernement n'a
papas de plan pour voir venir, t
lala croissance démographique va
fafaire en sorte... C'est commen
papaquebot, on voit ça venir de
loloin mais on n'agit pas.
CÇa va à peine réussir à combler
lala liste d'attente en ce mome.
QuQu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec
totous les baby-boomers qui s'en
viviennent et qui vont prendre e
dede l'âge? Les soins à domicil,
mamais ce n'est pas suffisant, n
esest très loin de combler les
bebesoins actuels. Ce n'est pas
unune façon de dire : bon, on va
ababandonner les gens à leur sot
chchez : en ce moment, il n'y a
auaucun plan de rattrapage qui t
fafait. Je pense que c'est à ça
ququ'on doit s'attaquer
mamaintenant.
- - Elle dit en d'autres mots ce
quque vous dîtes : la tempête qi
nonous a frappé une fenêtre en
lulumière... mais une réflexion
sosociétale doit être amorcée.
IlIl ne faut pas juste parler ds
sosoins à domicile quelquefois.
TrTrès bien. Voilà pour le rappt
KaKamel.
LaLa manifestation en fin de
sesemaine, on va voir des image,
àà Montréal, d'anglophones, mais
ilil y avait aussi des
frfrancophones, des gens qui
trtrouvent qu'avec projet de loi
9696, le gouvernement deviendra
tatatillon à certains endroits
dadans le domaine du travail, ou
vava restreindre inutilement trp
dede place dans les cégeps
ananglophones.
OnOn va écouter Madame Anglade i
ététait à la manifestation.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - C'est important de montrer
nonotre appui à la communauté.
PuPuis le premier message qu'on
dodoit lancer c'est que on est
trtrès conscient de l'importance
dede la langue française,
l'l'importance de la protection,
l'l'importance de la promotion.
MaMais il faut qu'on le fasse
dede manière inclusive. Il faut
ququ'on le fasse pour tous
leles Québécois et en ce sens,
lele projet de loi 96 ne répond
papas ces objectifs-là.
- - Certains ont dit que c'était
unune erreur, ou que c'était un
gegeste de désespoir. Comment
avavez-vous vu cette
paparticipation?
- - Je pense que Madame Anglade
rerevient à sa clientèle
trtraditionnelle. Depuis
l'l'élection partielle de Marie
ViVictorin, quelque chose s'est
papassé chez les libéraux. On a
vrvraiment prie conscience que e
vivirage à gauche de Madame
AnAnglade, ça ne marchait pas, t
ququ'elle s'en allait vers un mr
sisi elle continuait de ce côté-
llà. Sa clientèle traditionnelle
esest fâchée contre elle,
esessentiellement parce qu'ils
n'n'auront pas tenu compte de lr
poposition notamment sur la loi
9696, mais aussi concernant le
cocollège Dawson. Alors elle
rerevient à sa clientèle, et ele
veveut à certains égards sauvés
leles meubles, sauver les
cicirconscriptions qu'elle veut
gagarder.
- - Alec, sur le fond, je pense
quque vous l'avez vu en entrevue
cece midi, Madame Anglade dit :
lilimiter le nombre de
frfrancophones en cégeps
ananglophones, ce n'est pas une
bobonne idée. Est-ce qu'elle
auaurait pu être e plus clair? e
quque c'était plus clair avant.
- - C'est le changement de cap i
fafait mal à Madame Anglade. Ele
sesemblait vouloir travailler ac
SiSimon Jolin-Barrette, parce qe
l'l'influence de Lang à Montréal
etet véritable. Mais on a
l'l'impression que pour des
raraisons tactiques, politiques,
lele parti libéral va voter cone
etet participer à des
mamanifestations. Alors que il a
dedes problèmes dans ce projet e
loloi.
IlIl y a des choses, je pense à
obobliger les réfugiés d'un pays
enen guerre, apprend le français
enen six mois.
CÇa a pas de bon sens non plus.
MaMais c'est inscrit dans le
prprojet de loi. Il y aurait des
chchoses à corriger dans ce prot
dede loi, mais on n'en a fait...
etet beaucoup de gens ont adhérà
çaça. Ce qui fait que c'est
cocompliqué pour le parti libérl
dede se positionner après l'avor
bibien accueilli. Il y a des
papartis politiques qui vont se
crcréer il joue dans les...
ElElle en fait prix politique qi
esest important. Les francophons
vovont penser qu'elle est contre
lele projet de loi, et donc,
cocontre le français. Parce que
c'c'est ce qu'on martèle depuis
dedes mois du côté du
gogouvernement. C'est une positn
trtrès ingrate que le Parti
lilibéral actuellement est en
trtrain d'essayer de prendre.
- - Stéphanie, êtes-vous du même
avavis qu'il y aurait peut-être
fafallu dès le début elle soit
plplus clair, ou en tout cas, ps
dididactique sur ce qui allait
bibien et n'allait pas bien?
- - Si on se ramène en arrière,
avavant même le dépôt du projete
loloi 96, les libéraux poussaiet
popour avoir des avancées. Ce st
eueux-mêmes qui ont dit : ça
seserait bien d'appliquer ça aux
enentreprises de plus petite
tataille. Finalement, François
LeLegault a ajouté ça sur le ta.
PePersonnellement, je trouvais
ququand le projet a été déposé :
pepeut-être aurons-t-on une bele
coconjoncture, les astres seront
alalignés,s, tant au fédéral, qi
auau Québec, où on voyait même s
papartis de l'opposition se
popositionner pour justement la
dédéfense du français. Oui,
évévidemment, on est tous pour a
prprotection du français, c'est
ssûr et certain. Mais le débat,
ilil a pris une toururnure très
didivisée. Et les libéraux se st
chcherchés à travers ça. Il
rerevient maintenant à une
poposition plus historique, si e
pepeux dire. On le vit avec
MiMichelle Setlakwe, qui est
rerevenu en se présentant
auautrement Mont-Royal avec une
poposition beaucoup plus ferme.
MaMaintenant, Madame Anglade.
MaMaintenant, ça donne comme
imimpression qu'ils ne savent ps
dadans quelle direction ils von.
- - On peut difficilement être
cocontre certains éléments du
prprojet de loi 96 sans être ta,
cocomme vous l'avez dit, comme s
unun vrai québécois.
QuQuand j'ai vu ces tweets du cf
dede cabinet, la personne la pls
prproche de M. Legault, je vais
vovous montrer les tweets.
CÇa peut paraître un débat dans
lele cadre, mais ça révèle
d'd'autres choses.
IlIl est utile ici à ce débat de
poposer la question : est-il
apapproprié qu'un chef de cabint
s's'adresse à un des deux groups
imimportants, il y en a deux, on
nene fait pas de dessin...
esest-ce que c'est sa job de fae
çaça? N'y a-t-il pas un côté
mamalsain dans le débat?
- - C'est n'est pas n'importe ql
didirecteur de cabinet, c'est ln
dedes hommes les plus puissantsu
QuQuébec, c'est l'un des bras
drdroits de François Legault.
QuQuant au téléphone sonne et qe
c'c'est M. Koskinen qui appelle,
tutu réponds.
IlIl a la certitude que cette
pepersonne-là va prendre l'appel
etet qu'il pourra être entendu.l
y y a un petit côté signature-C.
CeCe n'est pas le seul conseillr
imimportant de M. Legault qui se
lalaisse aller à des tweets quad
ilils ne sont pas très satisfais
dede, soit d'une chronique, soit
d'd'un...
- - Il y a même en fin de
sesemaine...
- - Ou même à l'égard
d'd'adversaires politiques.
CeCes gens devraient s'élever
dadavantage, c'est quand même un
cacabinet de premier ministre.
- - Je pense que le débat est
inintéressant.
C'C'est des questions que les
jojournalistes et les médias se
poposent. C'est le genre de débt
ouoù, effectivement, on se
crcritique. Je ne suis pas certn
ququ'il est soulevé par la bonne
pepersonne. On a l'impression qe
totous les textes qui piquent la
CACAQ sont relevés par des
coconseillers de François Legau,
ququi se débattent sur les résex
sosociaux pourra être contre ci,
cocontre ça.
SaSa place "La Presse" dans une
poposition...
jeje pense que le débat est
inintéressant, mais je ne suis s
cecertain que c'est la bonne
pepersonne pour l'initier au
QuQuébec.
- - Vous aurez le temps voulu,
StStéphanie. Juste un mot : le
dédébat, c'est tout à fait saine
l'l'avoir. Est-ce que la presse
popourrait trop d'un côté, et
QuQuebecor trouve de l'autre?
PePeut-être plus de diversité.
DéDébat peut-être à faire... mas
d'd'un chef de cabinet?
- - D'abord, je trouve ça
paparticulièrement ironique la Q
nonous accuse d'avoir la pensée
ununique, parce que je trouve
nenettement que ils ont rendu
tetellement fort, et on leur doe
10100 députés, c'est quoi, ils n
vovoudraient plus? La critique,
c'c'est sain, mais on dirait qun
cece moment, dès qu'il a une
crcritique, le gouvernement est
dedevenu arrogant. Alors il sert
dodommage Teresa une députée de
QuQuébec solidaire qui pose des
ququestions très justifiées sure
sosort des parents qui n'ont pas
dede place en garderie. Il traie
dede complotistes un député
lilibéral qui s'objecte au
gogouvernement par décret. Ce qi
esest tout à fait légitime. Et i
onon revient au monde du
jojournalisme, M. Legault, pendt
lala pandémie, n'a pas ménagé, l
s's'est acharné sur un journalie
dede la gazette qui avait soule,
enen premier, tous les problèmes
dudu CHSLD Herron.
NoNotre association
prprofessionnelle vient de lui
dédécerner un prix. Je pense que
c'c'est la façon des journalists
dede répondre à ce genre
d'd'attaque. Je trouve que c'est
trtrès malsain de s'en prendre x
mémédias, des médias, c'est très
imimportant en démocratie. Je
pepense qu'il faut le rappeler n
cece moment, ce n'est pas en
lalançant ce genre d'attaque et
d'd'essayer de miner l'image des
mémédias...
dadans les pages que je dirige,l
y y a de la place pour toutes ls
opopinions, entre autres celle e
ChChristian Dufour, que vous avz
sosouvent au panel, avec qui jee
susuis pas toujours en accord,
mamais on finit à avoir un débat
coconstructif qui fait avancer a
didiscussion.
- - Vive la diversité d'opinion,
etet on va mieux s'emporter. Mei
àà vous trois! À très bientôt et
bobonne soirée.